well we've seen tyler malley enough this
season to know
the situation with him three and three
at home and
on the road just absolutely dominates
and the question is why i don't know if
we know why well it's got to be a mental
thing he just has not been able to
really be that stud pitcher that this
team needs him to be here at home
the 1-0 pounded right center field
pretty deep and castillanos reaches out
and that'll hop into the crowd a ground
rule double to start the night for
robbie grossman
breaks his back to india that'll freeze
the runner
flip to first retire scope grossman
forced to remain in second
india on the backhand sweep shovel
farmer the first not in time
grossman the third pretty play by india
they nearly turned two
another 3-2
and haas held off
bases are loaded with tigers
long inning for tyler o'malley getting
even longer now as he faces harold
castro
[Applause]
matt boyd on the mound for the tigers
been out over a couple months three and
seven record and the long ball has
haunted him this year in the last game
that happened on both basketballs he's
got a slider in the changeup and
hopefully he'll have a little more gas
in his tank tonight now matthew boyd
throws to his old teammate nick
castiano's
way out in front and he strikes him nice
even castillanos had to give a nod to
matthew boyd and appreciate that pitch
went away
way out in front you've been working it
inside you're still thinking about
getting the bad head out lefty on lefty
boyd against joey votto now
a check swing roller
boyd will tag vatto out it's out number
two in the inning
the payoff he got him swinging boyd
leaves a couple in scoring position
alley can be a slower burn but when he
catches fire he can be overwhelmingly
dominant
swing of the miss high fastball
you know you're going to get one
certainly not going to catch up to it up
there
oh two
swing of the miss
tyler o'malley has retired four in a row
three strikeouts in that time
here's the one two and he strikes him
out three punch outs for matthew boyd
one out in the second that's a good
corner if you can remember to keep it
out there
swung on and missed another strikeout
for matthew boyd his second of the
inning and fourth of the night 81 miles
an hour with that motion and just a
parachute on the end of that pitch
a chopper
to short harold castro throws out maui
matthew boyd strands another here's
robbie grossman who had a lead off
ground rule double
swing and a miss
four strikeouts for maui he's retired
five straight there's jonathan scove had
a huge night last night
a rocket to left center
aquino's gonna have to hurry
finally catches up to it but not before
jonathan scope jogs in with a one-out
double here in the third
[Applause]
o-two
swing of the miss struck him out
that time it's the slider didn't have
much of a break on it stayed out there
and remained out there there's two down
now two on leaves it up to eric haas
deep left center field that is a rocket
into the stands home run number 20 for
eric haas
and it's a three-nothing tigers lead
you watch this replay watch the pitcher
he didn't get this one where he wanted
it eric haas been following him off
he knew it
everybody in the ballpark knew it
if you catch up to a high fastball
you're going to hit it in the air hit
the ball in the air here in cincinnati
the ball is going to travel three
strikeouts in the inning a three-run
homer by eric haas
and it's classic stevenson going the
other way there is such a fun factor
from tyler stevenson nick castianos who
struck out breaking ball got him
swinging
castellanos to right center
all the way to the wall
house of thirds stop sign stevenson
standing double castianos
33 doubles for castianos joey vado
stands in
[Music]
breaks his back
splashes down base hit stevenson scores
castellano stop sign the bat nearly went
to the outfield
and bono gets the reds on the board it's
three to one
and hey eugenio suarez do um
that's in the air to right center
castillano set to tag up hill makes the
catch in medium right center throw to
the plate castiano's home and he crosses
sac fly rbi one run game
kyle farmer
grounds this one to the backhand costa
long throw
not in time
the reds have strung together a series
of really good plate appearances this
ending aquino walked his last time
aquino a blast to left
the punisher delivers
you know we talked about this team and
their ability to bounce back
how do you answer a three-run deficit
how about throw five up on the board
and the punisher coming up big on the
breaking ball
ground ball through the hole on the
right side another multi-hit game for
jonathan scope
a single to left scope forced to hold at
third the ball goes up the first base
line but not far enough for scope to
risk it bases are loaded for detroit for
dustin garneau
and they walked him
jonathan scope will score the tigers
have pulled to where they won tigers
within one and here's derek hill to try
and add to it
[Applause]
what makes a good pitcher
is a defender that can make that kind of
play behind it
nice play
well gino got a good break on this ball
right here
ranging to his right it's not an
unfamiliar position for him to be
playing especially with these guys
played shortstop in detroit
one two three inning for lorenzo
and with that joey botto is tied mr
tiger himself now k-line
for 49th on the all-time walk list
suarez joins bottle on the bases
back-to-back walks from jimenez two outs
tyler naquin to hit for aquino
broke his back fair ball
gets by cabrera
bottoms home
suarez to third he's given the wave
grossman from right fires in relay goes
to third suarez scores and nick went to
third base
a two run triple reds up 7-4
and that ball just hugging the corner
tyler naked with plenty of time to float
into third base
double play ball suarez india
double play
the reds top the tigers 7-4
they'll hold on to their wild card
position in the standings tomorrow and
they'll have a chance to claim the
series
you